[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir le sommaire de ce jeudi 21 mars
l'état devront tourner à la maison de
quartier louis jouvet de montigny le
bretonneux ce week end un jeune de la
ville organise un ton à de toupies
beyblade
nous avons suivi les derniers
préparatifs le salon des arts revient à
saint cyr l'école depuis près de 30 ans
les artistes exposent leurs oeuvres dans
l'espoir de se voir remettre un prix
marie-laure rousseau conseillère
municipale en charge de la culture sera
avec nous pour la première fois la ferme
de la tramblais ouvre ses portes à un
large public
l'occasion de fêter le printemps et de
découvrir les métiers de cette ferme en
agroécologie ce samedi 23 mars aura lieu
à montigny le bretonneux en tout premier
tournoi de toupies beyblade
il est organisé par le conseil municipal
des jeunes à l'initiative de maxence un
jeune unis montrent un passionné nous
sommes allés à sa rencontre avec manou
varaldo à 13 ans maxence a une passion
une toupie
mais attention pas n'importe quel toupet
les beyblade loin de la toupie en bois
celle ci est très sophistiqué et maxence
les connaît par coeur salle elle
s'appelle ce prix gagnent requiem
donc elle vient en luge avant sa pointe
c'est rien que ça pointe trois capacités
là c'est une boule normal donc de type
défense quand on lève et on tourne on a
un truc plat pour l'attack pour retenir
tous et non pas trop compliqué et ben en
fait je me tiens je me dis ça aussi et
en fait ce nom parce que je sais ça
prend pas ça rentre dans ma tête tout
seul
et donc là ces galaxies de tron qui a
gagné parce que celle ci s'est arrêtée
en premier au total il en possède 70
avec des lanceurs étaient à rennes pour
faire de combat attention 3 2 1
le père une passion que maxence aime
partager notamment avec son petit frère
on sait partage trophée des grimpeurs
ont semblé parfois avec mon père ou mère
ou ma grand-mère même avec ses camarades
du collège il a même monté un club de
beyblade
alors naturellement il a souhaité
apporter cet univers dans sa ville son
idée créer un tournoi pour trouver de
l'aide
né vers le conseil municipal des jeunes
à mon top départ va falloir qu'on se
fasse une réunion d'arbitrage dont on se
réunit tous et ensuite on met change les
rôles maxence il est venu nous a proposé
d'organiser un tournoi de tous qu'il est
parler est ton était motivée alors on
l'a fait de l'instance à ce que ça fait
quelques mois qu'on sentait starmine
enfin content qu'on puisse le faire
dernière réunion avant le grand jour du
tournoi les jeunes ont travaillé durant
un trimestre pour que tout se passe bien
des idées c'est les leurs
les commandes scellé leur donc moi je ne
fais que transmettre leurs idées je
peaufine mais sinon mais on peut dire
qu'ils ont fait de a à z heures ce
samedi maxence aura l'honneur d'arbitrer
la grande finale
prochaine étape pour le champion le
tournoi officiel de parler d'eux où il
espère bien remporter sa place pour la
grande finale de la japan expo
il reste encore quelques places pour
s'inscrire au tournoi il aura lieu
samedi 23 mars à la maison de quartier
louis jouvet de 14h30 à 18h pour vous
inscrire et vous suffit de vous rendre
au pôle jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux jusqu'au 27 mars
l'art sous de multiples formes a investi
le théâtre gérard philipe de saint cyr
l'école celle là le 27ème salon des arts
qui accueille 36 artistes avec nos
emplettes au mali l'heure où sort vous
son pardon vous êtes conseiller
municipal chargé de la culture bonjour
bonjour
alors tout d'abord est ce que vous nous
expliquer ce qu'est que ce salon des
arts à saint cyr l'école et bien comme
vous l'avez dit c'est un salon qui a
déjà 27 ans et 27e édition qui est déjà
bien installée à saint cyr il a été créé
pour faire émerger tous les talents qui
existent sur la commune et leur permet
d'avoir un premier lieu d'exposition de
pouvoir se confronter une première fois
avec le public
voilà notre rôle aussi c'est
d'accompagner ces artistes nous
cherchons à développer et entretenir le
tissu artistique locale et à travers les
réunions d'artistes il ya des échanges
qui sont fructueux et les artistes
s'enrichissent aussi mutuellement des
échanges entre artistes mais aussi un
enjeu parce qu'il ya plusieurs prix qui
sont remis et vous vous êtes fait partie
d'une membre du jury
voilà moi je fais partie de membres du
jury mais nous sommes quatre il ya aussi
mon professeur de peinture est au coeur
de l'année dernière voilà exactement et
le vainqueur de l'année dernière qui a
eu le prix spécial du jury
et puis madame torki et moi même voilà
tous ces prix seront remis lors du
vernissage le samedi 23 mars
l'exposition continue avec un prix du
public
voilà donc on a à coeur aussi de faire
participer le public
et ils sont très nombreux donner leur
avis donc il ne sera pas décerner le
jour du vernissage mais une semaine
après on les prévient on est prêt vient
et c'est toujours un prix un petit peu
différent mais c'est très intéressant
d'avoir l'avis du public
alors ce salon il évolue on a dit la 27
ans au départ les artistes étaient
essentiellement évinois mais la
directrice du salon français du kiné a
ouvert les portes à toute l'île de
france
voilà ce qu'est une évolution qui s'est
fait naturellement parce que
effectivement comme c'est un salon
amateurs il est très attractif
tous les amateurs peuvent s'y présenter
il ya une ouverture est donc tout
naturellement on est venu à élargir et
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui
sont des départements autour de paris dd
de l'essonne des hauts-de-seine donc il
ya une ouverture très large qui s'est
faite à l'occasion de ce salon qui nous
verture sur le territoire mais aussi des
styles il ya une nouvelle catégorie
cette année
voilà bien nous avons introduit cette
année le street art
voilà nous sommes très contents devant
cette nouvelle catégorie qui permet
peut-être de cibler un public plus jeune
et nous avons déjà des ailes de street
art qui seront récompensées sûrement
cette année voilà et si on revient un
peu sur l'historique de ce salon
pourquoi avoir installé un salon des
terres comme ça à saint cyr l'école
non mais pour nous c'est très important
d'établir un lien de proximité entre les
habitants et l'art ça fait partie de
notre mission
voilà il ça ne nous le savons nous
voulons offrir une production de qualité
et puis nous cherchons toujours avec des
tarifs très très accessible à facilités
l'accès de la population aux arts
visuels mais aussi à tous les âges
la musique la littérature d'apparat de
là il était retrouvé ses 94 ans j'ai vu
qu'il était exposé ou alors c'est au
théâtre gérard-philipe rue gérard
philipe
or là il n'y a pas d'âge reste plus
précise que ça mais il est facile à
trouver
voilà et jusqu'au 27 mars et même si
vous pouvez vous pouvez même voter pour
le prix du public dans les petites
boîtes merci marie laure rousseau d'être
venu sur le plateau imprime aussi je
vous remercie l'association éclat
d'orgue à lévis en on organise un
concert hommage à jean guillou célèbre
organiste de saint-eustache et président
d'honneur de l'association il s'est
éteint il ya un mois son dernier
disciples jean baptiste mono
s'installera au clavier vendredi 22 mars
à 20h30 à l'église de sainte de lévis en
découvrir les facettes méconnues de la
vie d'un roi c'est le programme du jeu
de piste familial organisé par aventure
culturelle au château de versailles
destiné aux enfants à partir de 7 ans et
leurs parents vous pourrez répondre aux
questions des organisateurs samedi 23
mars de 14h à 16h le retour de la
relation mère-fille selon lisa azuelos
et des rebelles de la boîte de conserve
c'est votre rendez vous dans les salles
saint-quentinoise de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine au ciné c'est du 20 au 26
mars plein de belles choses à voir
d'excellents films de très bons films
je vais commencer par les excellents que
je vais citer rapidement qui conte à la
fiche depuis un certain temps mais qu'il
faut absolument voir grâce à dieu de
françois ozon évidemment la favorite
l'excellent film du réalisateur grèce et
leurs gosses lanthimos le mystère épique
et green book qui a eu comme vous savez
un oscar à hollywood et aussi cette
semaine de très bonnes comédies à la
fiche
la première c'est bon bébé de lisa
azuelos avec sandrine kiberlain qui
raconte un peu les affres pour une maman
du départ en fait de l'enfant de l'aîné
de la maison c'est pas toujours facile
donc le film en parle avec finesse et
tendresse et le second sur tous ces
rebelles qui est un film d'hana mauduit
avec un trio assez soucieux cécile de
france
audrey lamy qui est l'excellente yolande
moreau les deux autres étant que celles
en touche alors c'est quoi cette
histoire c'est l'histoire de trois
ouvrières dans une usine de fabrication
de boîtes de curseur de poissy qui vont
se rebeller un petit peu contre leur
chef
on trouve qu'elles subissent au
quotidien alors c'est assez trash mais
il faut le voir c'est du tarantino à la
française on va dire donc attendez vous
à quelque chose qui déménage qui revue
et donc c'est à voir dans nos salles
cette semaine au 6 décembre
hormis a disparu avec le pognon des
belges pourquoi tu leur a pas dit qu'on
quoi tu te fasses écrite avec ma
[Musique]
pour fêter le printemps la ferme de la
tramblais qui produit du fromage vous
invite à une journée portes ouvertes
gratuites pour découvrir ces activités
démonstrations de bûcheronnage atelier
plantation de pommiers traite des
chèvres
les activités seront variés de 10h à 18h
l'occasion également de rencontrer les
professionnels de cette ferme en
agroécologie 10 pour les plus gourmands
un marché fermier sera installé olivier
veilleux vous présente le programme
on va accueillir différents producteurs
de du du département des yvelines et on
va faire également découvrir nos
activités
donc que ce soit la partie agriculture
la partie élevage
la partie production de fromage mais
également tout ce qui est production
d'énergie il ya des activités qui sont
dédiés aux enfants
comme la découverte des différentes
céréales et et culture que l'on que l'on
peut faire ici
il y aura également des visites
extérieur de la fromagerie et des
dégustations évidemment à travers le
marché fermier qui est un qui sera
ouverte ce jour là une course de drones
dans le noir avec des guirlandes
lumineuses estaca modélisme l'une des
associations de l'école d'ingénieurs de
montigny le bretonneux organise cette
compétition pour la troisième année
vous pouvez y assister dans le parking
de l'estaca samedi 23 mars de 9h à 18h
les cougars reprennent du service pour
cette première journée ils affronteront
les cavigal nice ces samedi et dimanche
23 et 24 24 mars au centre sportif jean
maréchal de montigny le bretonneux la
saison dernière et s'était incliné en
finale face à rouen on leur souhaite un
tout aussi joli parcours et pourquoi pas
un titre pour cette nouvelle saison
on part à paris et londres sur un air de
reggae le palais de la porte dorée dans
le 12e arrondissement de paris accueille
l'exposition musique migration trois
décennies d'histoire et d' influence
musicale entre funk reggae et encore
zouk raconté jusqu'au 5 janvier 2020
reportage de paul vi look et de nos
confrères dia grand paris une exposition
haute en couleurs et en musique
s'installe au palais de la porte dorée
paris/londres musique migration revient
sur 3 dessiné d'histoire et d' influence
musicale entre funk reggae ou encore
zouk l'exposition explore différents
courante et ce au delà de simples
chansons
politique migration racisme c'est un
retour sur le passé postcoloniale de
deux villes fortement impacté par les
mouvements migratoires
ce sont deux ancienne capitale des
empires qui se transforme en métropole
de l'immigration à partir des années 60
donc on commence l'exposition à 1962
parce que 1962 c'est l'indépendance à la
fois de l'algérie mais aussi de la
jamaïque
donc à partir de cette date et des
sujets de l'empiré britannique vous mon
français qui était venu s'installer à
paris et à londres deviennent les
nationaux de pays indépendant et pour
raconter l'histoire de leur installation
mais doit aussi de leurs revendications
puis contribution à l'identité de ces
deux villes à la musique vous a paru
l'un des moyens les plus illustrateurs
et les plus riches des années 60 à la
fin des années 80 musique migration met
en lumière des artistes phares tels que
bob marley bien sûr mais aussi manu
dibango ou encore le groupe kassav à
travers une exposition construite comme
un parcours qui change selon les années
ce qui était frappant pour nous ces
caves et des contextes historiques
vraiment différent donc l'exposition
elle est organisée de manière à faire
revivre ces contextes aux visiteurs on
commence par les années 60 à paris et à
londres
on a des espaces dédiés à paris des
espaces dédiés à londres et puis les
espaces de rencontres aussi et puis on
fait une petite pause dans un espace
qu'on a appelé le studio qui est
l'atelier des musiciens ou là on a des
instruments musique qui sont présentés
par des artistes et c'est tous ces
instruments qui sont essentiels aux
musiciens lorsqu'ils enregistrent leur
musique et on a ensuite une pièce
consacrée aux années 70 et puis on
termine par les années 80 ludique
migration une exposition bien orchestrée
à découvrir jusqu en janvier 2020 et
c'est la fin de votre site choisi
remercie nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles et des sorties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh